Hi there, this is Steve, co-founder of LingQ. Someone who is enjoying learning languages.
I learned about nine of them
up to the age of sixty and I've learned
another nine in the last ten or so years.
And I know very well that in language learning
first of all, everyone can do it,
everyone can do it, it doesn't take a
special talent, although you get better
the more languages you learn. And it
consists of three absolutely important
keys. The first one is your attitude.
Are you interested? Do you like the
language? Do you like learning it?
Do you believe in the system? Do you think you're gonna get there? You have to be positive.
That's the first. The second of
all, you have to spend the time, find the time, listen.
Ten minutes here, Fifteen minutes there.
You have to find the time and work
on your LingQs. And the third thing is
developing the ability to notice what's
happening in the language, but that comes.
If you have the attitude, if you spend
the time, you will start to notice the language
and you are going to learn.
Take it from me.